je suis de retour après un long mois et
demi à être sur la route avec amazon
pour l'émission ça va cartonner
me voilà de retour tournage quasiment
terminée mais pour l'instant en tout cas
l'arrêt donc je suis là je suis avec
vous et on va pouvoir avancer sur nombre
de tests nombreux produits que j'ai chez
moi et sur les cas il faut que j'avance
si on va commencer aujourd'hui par cette
montre la fin non non je vous dirais
plutôt cette montrera c'est l'apple
world series si ce que j'ai déjà depuis
nombreux jours à mon poignet et que du
coup je connais quand même plutôt pas
mal donc on va en parler on va regarder
si elle est intéressante si elle est
faite pour vous je suis à l'air est
frais qui arrive même plus à parler si
elle est faite pour vous qu'est ce
qu'elle peut vous apporter
et surtout cet appel web série 6 elle
est vraiment intéressante parce qu'il
faut vraiment différencier deux points
essentiels le hardware le software le
hardware c'est le matériel le software
c'est tout ce qui est logiciel et puis
on se parlera d'ici quelques jours de
cette deuxième montre de apple c'est
l'apple watch est ce le modèle moins
cher à 299 euros mais ça on en parle en
quelques jours d'ailleurs que tout
savoir sur cette montre là et surtout
mes produits qui arrivent et tous les
tests et croyez-moi ghana énormément on
a même parlé de l'iphone 12 pro on va
pas de beaucoup de choses et bien je
vous invite à venir vous abonnez vous
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge qui
situent juste ici en bas vous accédez la
cloche que ça vous serez notifié dès qu
une prochaine vidéo rivera et ça c'est
très cool comme je le disais quand on
parle d'un produit comme celui là il
faut vraiment différencier la partie
logicielle de la partie matérielle et
c'est extrêmement important pourquoi je
donne dans l'île puisque la partie
matérielle et la réelle nouveauté de
cette montre c'est réellement ce qu'on
peut venir faire avec cette montre est
uniquement avec cette notre la partie
logicielle à savoir ici web os 7
eh bien on peut le trouver dans d'autres
montré notamment dans l'appel aux hcl et
5,2 les dernières une expérience plus
fluide plus de choses à faire c'est très
content aussi tout ça donc ça c'est
vraiment deux points qui font vraiment
distinguer c'est extrêmement important
et ça va être le fil conducteur dans
tout cette vidéo pour vraiment parler de
cette montre et réussir à la comprendre
on est toutes nouvelles couleurs et moi
j'ai modèle bleu c'est vrai que ce petit
côté bleu très sympa c'est une des
nouveautés et la couleur rouge le
producteur ed avec lequel apple
travaille notamment la lutte contre le
sida avec une association américaine
donc ça c'est plutôt sympa j'ai un petit
bracelet bleu qui marchera très bien
avec alors que ti brasse le pot venir
changer première nous
c'est le solo loupe alors si vous aimez
le mélange des couleurs vert et bleu est
bien là vous allez être heureux
en fait ce que c'est ça c'est que c'est
un seul bracelet qui vous avez de venir
vous arracher les points ce que je
reproche toujours à ces bracelets l'a
donc là vous prenez hop là vous le passé
comme ça il ya un peu trop grand pour ma
taille je vous le dirai tout de suite
mais ça va dépendre et plusieurs taipei
1 va choisir directement sur le site
d'apple vous venez l'enfiler très
facilement c'est très pratique ça c'est
cool ça n'a fait ça c'est le premier
bracelet et deuxième bracelet et ça va
être un bracelet en cuir et mentez vous
venez le positionner vous n'avez qu'à
trouver la bonne dimension et ça vient
se clipser extrêmement facilement et ça
je trouve ça vraiment mais vraiment très
très très très pratique mais je dirais
qu'un des gros points forts de cette
montre est bien vient d'un capteur qui
est tout nouveau qui va pouvoir venir
mesurer la saturation votre sang
l'oxygène alors ça ça me plaît ça ça me
plaît parce qu'on vient vraiment allier
une nouvelle techno qui a ajouté à cette
montre au niveau matériel et une
nouvelle fonctionnalité logiciel on a
donc un mariage parfait entre le
hardware et le software qui n'est pas
remis uniquement ici que sur cette
montre ça m'intéresse mais est-ce que je
vais pour autant moi en tout cas avant
le besoin de mesurer la saturation en
oxygène dans mon sang je ne suis pas sûr
je ne suis pas sûr mais par contre ce
que ça montre aussi extrêmement
intéressant et bien c'est l'ouverture
toujours plus large à la santé apple
avait commencé avec son cadeau fréquence
mail pour savoir à quel rythme battez
votre coeur on a eu ensuite le cg
l'électrocardiogramme pour savoir si
vous aviez un problème de fibrillation
ventriculaire qu'on savoir si tout était
ok au niveau de votre coeur et l'apple
va encore plus loin avec une nouvelle
mesure de santé à savoir l la saturation
en oxygène et ce qui est super
intéressant la dansé devant le
positionnement de la marque
le positionnement de l'objet de la
montre puisqu'on n'est plus ici que sur
une monde connecté à quoi vous sert ou
le monde connecté c'est toujours la
question laquelle essaye de répondre
les fabricants en créant des usages en
apportant de nouvelles fonctionnalités
et bien une monde connecté c'est un
objet qu'on a en permanence au poignet
vous apprends rien connectez parce
qu'elle est connecté à votre smartphone
qui vous parle de récupérer des dates à
des informations qu'on peut convertir
pour apporter des usages les usages ici
moins que les usages de santé pour vous
améliorer votre vie on connaissait la
monde connecté qui était vraiment un
atout essentiel pour le sport et ça
l'est toujours avec pleins
d'applications des applications sport on
ira dans quelques instants
mais surtout au jeu
lui c'est un outil de santé
multigénérationnel s'adresse bien
évidemment aux enfants on en parle aussi
dans quelques instants aux adultes mais
également aux seniors aux à bull puisque
oui les pathologies cardiaques peuvent
toucher tout le monde aujourd'hui on
parle de pathologies cardiaques
j'imagine qu'avec d'autres capteurs qui
arriveront ultérieurement
on pourra aller encore plus loin
peut-être va-t-on réussir dans les
années à venir a parlé aux diabétiques
années à venir à mesurer son taux de
glycémie ça me parait tracés d'adn mais
pourquoi pas ça va toujours plus loin on
ne s'adresse plus uniquement à la
personne parfaite à la personne parfaite
qui fait du sport on s'adresse à tout le
monde
d'une très bonne manière et ça c'est
plutôt bien et c'est bien vu de la part
d'apple
alors attention ici on va venir
monitorer des données de santé il y a
des limites
on n'est pas ici sur un dispositif
médical ça reste une monde connecté si
vous avez des problèmes de santé il vous
faut des outils pour venir mesurer tout
ça pour des données probablement plus
fiable pour transmettre à votre médecin
dans le cadre d'un suivi de santé
néanmoins si vous avez des indicateurs
des indicateurs qui sont quand même
suffisamment fiable et suffisamment
pertinent pour pouvoir savoir ce qu'il
en est tout en sachant qu'au niveau de
la saturation en oxygène si vous avez
une peau qui est tatoué ça ne marchera
pas si votre montre est mal positionné
ça ne fonctionnera pas si votre
perfusion cutanée n'est pas bonne cinq
photographes pas non plus mais pour
quasiment tout le monde
et bien c'est un super outil et on se
retrouve vraiment extrêmement pertinent
et ils vont encore plus loin au niveau
de la santé en parlant de sommeil alors
moi je ne suis pas un bon client pour ça
je ne dors pas être ma montre je n'aime
pas voir quelque chose au poignet
lorsque je dors mais si pour vous c'est
le cas vous pouvez faire pour y
surveiller votre cycle de sommeil savoir
si vous dormez bien ça s'inscrit une
fois de plus dans la santé oms des
personnes qu'on peut potentiellement
imaginer que c'est pas moi faire des
apnées du sommeil et bien prévenir
monitorer vous avez pas mal
d'indicateurs et une fois de plus
inscrit dans cette logique de santé
d'apple et c'est très malin
regardez par exemple est venu rechercher
mon application sommeil qui est juste là
j'ai mon heure de coucher l'heure à
laquelle je me réveille le matin oui bah
oui faut emmener yacht à l'école maria
notre outil qui est aussi très très très
cool et très malin au niveau des
applications et bien c'est pour venir
monitorer le bruit extérieur ont laissé
dans une pièce où il ya un peu moins de
40 des bd que je parle on a 60 70 des
mais quand je parle fort et bien voyez
c'est bruyant c'est vraiment vous
alerter en disant attention vous vous
exposez quand je parle très fort si vous
restez trop longtemps écouté clients
dans vos oreilles
eh bien ça peut être très mauvais pour
votre santé donc en fonction de
l'endroit où vous allez être vous avez
un petit doute vous venez lui demander
ça vous permet d'avoir l'information
directement et ça c'est fiable de la
même manière dans votre menu principal
vous allez dans appels d'urgence et vous
pouvez activer la détection de chute
donc là on s'adresse plus
particulièrement aux personnes en bonne
santé jeunes mais plutôt aux seniors et
c'est là où on voit que le choix d'un
peu extrêmement pertinent et très
intéressant c'est qu'on s'adresse pas
uniquement aux personnes en bonne santé
on s'adresse aux malades en s'adresse
aux personnes fragiles aux personnes
isolées
si j'ai une détection de chute bon
c'était le cas dans ma famille par
exemple ma grand mère avant qu'elles
n'aient vivre en ehpad est bien retombée
chez elle est il important toutes les
personnes âgées qui vivent seules de
pouvoir alerter les secours en cas de
chute alors il existe des dispositifs
vous mettez autour de votre cou vous
sonnez et ça appelle les pompiers qui
vont pouvoir intervenir mais si la
personne oublie son beat ce qui a
souvent été le cas et bien avoir une
montre au poignet peut vraiment avoir un
sens alors une fois de plus attention à
la barrière technologique on s'adresse
aux seniors est ce que les seniors ont
pensé à tout le temps bien chargé leurs
montres à la remettre de la bonne
manière
peut-être peut-être pas en attendant
apple l'intérieur à sa montre et je
trouve ça quand même rassurant et très
pertinent et l'apple ii typiquement
répondre à un problème comment la
technologie peut servir
nous vous apporter ou pas une meilleure
qualité de vie mais pendule garantir
votre santé apple dell à répondre à un
vrai problème de société comment nos
outils technologiques pour nous
permettre de mieux vivre plus en
sécurité avec plus d'un fonds plutôt
qu'être un énième gadget qui nous
servira pour aller notamment faire la
course c'est à dire de faire la course
est justement parlons également ce sport
parce que will happen loi que c'est pas
nouveau est une montre qui sert aux
sports c'était un des premiers
positionnement de la monde connecté pas
seulement apple de tout le monde c'est
le sport puisque va pouvoir récupérer un
petit peu de bata grâce à ces objets là
à peu continuer à capitaliser dessus à
nous proposer de nouvelles
fonctionnalités
on va essayer notamment avoir un
altimètre en plus des gyroscopes et
compagnie on connaissait avant on a donc
une montre qui permettra de récupérer
aussi beaucoup de données pour ceux qui
font du sport que vous soyez en
extérieur en salle en piscine je sais
qu'en ce moment avec le confinement
c'est un peu compliqué mais si vous
souhaitez faire du sport à la maison et
bien avec la période celle ci pourra
continuer à le faire
n'étant pas moi même un très grand
sportif j'ai pas avoir énormément
d'applications pour le sport hormis
celles déjà installées par apple vous
avez donc beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
sport que ce soit de la marge de la
course
bon je passe un peu plus qu'un petit peu
standard tout ça on connaîtra
intérieur/extérieur salle et compagnie
ça je vous disais quelques instants vous
pouvez faire beaucoup de choses même de
la danse mais c'était de faire ça à la
maison de mon petit peu de danse pour de
m sport récupération gainage la piscine
oui vous pouvez l'emmener et vous pouvez
l'emmener dans l'eau jusqu'à 50 mètres
une fois de plus je ne suis pas sportif
donc j'ai pas vous montrer grand chose
là dessus mais vous pouvez le faire et
ça c'est bien moi ce que j'apprécie
beaucoup c'est que lorsque je suis en
train de marcher bell média
il me semblerait monsieur que vous êtes
en train de marcher on commence
entraînements sassou sa pratique et ça
me le rappelle ici c'est plus une
question de logiciels que réellement de
matériel nisa par l'altimètre sauf si
vous allez en montagne mais au-delà de
ça mais attention je sais pas si vous
êtes comme moi si vous êtes un petit
boulet vous êtes toujours tendance à
petit peu à vous rapprocher trop près
des murs et à frotter et bien si vous
voulez dire protéger votre montre et
éviter qu'elles seraient et qu'elle ne
sans dommage
eh bien il existe une solution celle de
rhinau chine regardez-moi 56 millions
pour mieux protéger votre montre alors
je vous montre le fonctionnement comme
ça vous saurez tout c'est très facile
vous ouvrez la boîte et vous récupérez
introduit qu'à l'intérieur
parce que là vous aurez compris vous
venez prendre votre montre et vous la
mettez à l'intérieur vounet ensuite
remettre votre petit bracelet et vouloir
positionner à votre poignet ça devient
vous la protéger de tous les côtés vous
allez pas l'affronter sur le dessus il
ya un côté pratique se rassurant si elle
vous intéresse je vous ai mis le lien en
bas d'un description vous avez un code
promo a qu'une remise monsieur heureux
et ça c'est très très cool
cette montre est là surtout un intérêt
au niveau de l'écosystème parce que
c'est un produit qu'il a bien fonctionné
bien évidemment avec les produits
d'apple avec son iphone parce que je ne
vois pas bien l'intérêt d'acheter une
apple watch si vous n'avez pas un iphone
puisque vous ne pouvez pas l'utiliser ne
pourrait pas le tibet moi par exemple je
travaille sur un macbook pro macbook pro
parce qu'on utilise final cut pro pour
faire mes montages vidéo et le tout est
très pratique c'est que lorsque je
m'approche de mon macbook pro eh bien
elle reconnaît un autre
ldb rouille extrêmement rapidement pas
deux autres positionner mont noir sur
child is allez les rouges c'est pratique
et ça c'est bien de la même manière
lorsque je suis en déplacement jeudi
dans un train ou dans un avion
elia je me coûte de la musique je n'ai
pas besoin de prendre lancement cloud
qui est dans ma poche pour venir changer
mon morceau je fais directement avec mon
apple watch que ce soit sur spotify ou
sur n'importe quel service c'est très
pratique
j'ai accès à les playlists je peux
modifier
avec ma couronne je viens monter je
viens de baisser le son et des djs comme
ça il y en a énormément d'élan vous avez
activé apple paye vous arrivez pour
payer directement avec votre montre vous
avez accès votre application plan c'est
pas celle que je préfère mais je préfère
quand même google maps que je trouve
beaucoup plus pratique beaucoup mieux
construits j'imagine que apple va
continuer à travailler sa copie pour
nous proposer un logiciel toujours plus
performants en attendant points rend
votre plan sur votre apple ou h pour
vous diriger d'orange vie tout
simplement
dès lors qu'on pourra sortir de chez soi
vous pouvez répondre à un appel très
facilement vous pouvez répondre à un sms
grâce à la dictée vocale
vous avez également vos billets d'avion
à l'intérieur faria beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités je
trouve ça extrêmement pertinent une fois
de plus c'est un produit qui s'inscrit
dans l'écosystème apple c'est une monde
qui est disponible en 40 ou 44 mm ici
c'est un 44 mm mais je peux avoir le
modèle 46 je le souhaite et si j'ai des
plus petits poignets venir changer les
cadrans très facilement y en a plein en
fonction de mon humeur en fonction des
besoins content de ce que je souhaite
c'est aussi très très très très pratique
et surtout une des nouvelles
fonctionnalités de cette montre que
uniquement lasserre et 6 vous propose et
bien c'est un écran qui est allumée en
permanence cette nouvelle fonctionnalité
vous est permis grâce à la nouvelle puce
s 6 et 7 pouces et 6 elle vous apporte
aussi beaucoup plus de fluidité une
navigation qui est optimale qui amélioré
par rapport aux autres montre parce que
oui vous pouvez avoir moins chaud s7
dans votre apple watch serré 5 même si
vous allez gagner un corps fluidité
grâce à la mise à jour mais malgré tout
vous n'irez pas aussi loin que ce que
vous allez pouvoir faire avec votre
apple watch & rice et ça me paraît
normal
apple a aussi fait un très gros focus
haut niveau la réducation niveau des
matériaux ici j'ai une montre en
aluminium vous pouvez également avoir
une montre en titane ou encore en acier
inoxydable tous à 100% recyclé
l'aluminium restant la montre la moins
chère et si vous souhaitez monter sur le
titane et compagnie plus l'addition va
augmenter à savoir qu'ici on est quand
même sur une addition base à 429 euros
autant vous dire que c'est quand même
pas la montre la moins chère pour avoir
une nouvelle apple watch moins cher
c'est celle là celle d'apple watch est
ce une fois de plus je ne vous en parle
dans quelques jours le temps de
remballer celle là puisque vous ce soir
je termine le test de celle là je la
remballe jeu la rançon qui tu es tu es
jeune et celle là au poignet pendant
quelques temps ce qui fait je vous en
parlerai très bientôt - c'est là et ce
en 44 mm et je suis sûr qu'on aura plein
de belles choses à se raconter dessus la
pelouse était jusqu'à présent
individuel vous aviez votre iphone vous
veniez synchroniser votre apple watch
vous l'utilisez ont produit écosystèmes
du matin pour aller encore plus loin
puisque wii avec un seul iphone vous
pouvez venir synchroniser plusieurs un
peu vache ça c'est de la nouveauté
logiciel et non matériel on peut donc le
faire avec les anciens modèles
moi par exemple je suis père aujourd'hui
elliott est un peu petit ya sept ans
mais dans quelques années peut-être
voudra-t-il une apple watch est liée à
ce moment là sans forcément de clients
iphone je pourrais lui acheter d'apple
watch il a donc pouvoir la boire avec
des fonctionnalités adaptées à son âge
puisque wii u un mode école il ya un
autre devoir pour qu'il ne soit pas
d'istres et quand il est à l'école sans
quoi on aura pas d'appel watch ça c'est
papa qui le dit et de la même manière on
voit que c'est également une montre qui
se destine aux seniors et notamment avec
la détection de chute
on est donc une montre
multigénérationnel maintenant la
question est faut-il acheter cet appel
au match ça c'est la vraie question
c'est la question la plus intéressante
dans l'absolu - la peur watch je les
aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup le travail
qui est fait au niveau d'apple dans son
écosystème je voulais décrit sur les
différents usages aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres fabricants aussi qu'ils
développent tous ces écosystèmes ça
devient un vrai intérêt stratégique pour
toutes les marques
on rentre dans un écosystème par un
smartphone on s'étend pas un ordinateur
une montre et l'objectif des marques
c'est que vous ayez la complète et vous
souhaite tout on chez eux alors on sait
que c'est pas forcément hyper évident
notamment si vous êtes sur android mais
là où un peu ils sont très très malin et
bien c'est que qu'est ce qui va venir un
peu tenir cet écosystème
c'est le logiciel ca ios c'est là qu est
ce c'est un watch os qui fonctionne
merveilleusement bien le concert qui
fonctionne surtout pas avec le reste
maintenant la question est ce qu'il vous
faut acheter cet apple watch série 6
ma réponse va être très clair si vous
n'avez pas d'apple watch si vous avez un
iphone aussi lu proust d'achat d'iphone
vous voulez une très jolie nom de
connecter la paix watchers ici c'est
vraiment extrêmement cool si maintenant
vous voulez pas mettre 429 euros on
voulait mettre un petit peu moins
d'argent
eh bien je pense que l'apple watch est
ce peut être très intéressante la
réponse dans quelques jours une fois de
plus
abonnez-vous comme ça vous serez tous
mais la paloise series 5 fera également
très très bien à faire dans la mesure où
vous ne voulez pas un écran qui est
allumée en permanence
jour vous ne voulez pas mesurer votre
saturation du sang en oxygène dans la
mesure où vous n'avez pas besoin de
l'altimètre est bien là cinq ira très
très bien maintenant si vous avez déjà
1,5 ou une 4 il est absolument aucun
intérêt à venir sur ce modèle là dans
l'usure votre mesure de saturation en
oxygène mais pas indispensable pour vous
aux angels en a éliminé quand même une
grosse partie de la population - l'appel
matches serrés 6 j'aime beaucoup la
trouve très intéressante très bien
fabriqué il ya des nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui arrive apple fait
évoluer sa montre ça reste un objet
toujours plus coquets toujours plus
malin toujours plus performants et
personnellement j'aime bien et s'il vous
intéresse je ne peux que vous la
recommande et 7eme ouvreuse vous fait
des gros bisous prenez soin de vous des
décors de l'amour et on se retrouve
d'ici quelques jours pour parler de ça
on se retrouve d'ici quelques jours pour
parler de ça est très rapidement pour
parler tout le reste parce que croyez
moi il ya tellement de choses j'ai pris
tellement de retard en octobre que la le
20 novembre m hardcore de chez accor je
vous embrasse des bisous ciao
[Musique]